okay good evening ladies and gentlemen
welcome to planning West my name is
Justin carriage on the chair in front of
me are other counselors ward members who
are on the committee making decisions
either side of me our offices the
council who will help us in those
decisions and if I can ask them to
introduce themselves committee services
brass chambers legal services my name's
Richard Gardner and the planning manager
my role is as an impartial adviser to
the committee and I can clarify any
planning issues that arise doing so I'm
bound by the code of Professional
Conduct of the rural town planning
institute and planning committee members
are not bound by case officer advice or
by the officers recommendation
Alex cosmetics Senior Planner polities
good evening John careful policy manager
enterprise housing and planning so to
the gender apologies of absence
apologies from councillor Perry in
counts of Audrey thank you disclosures
of interest council organ 1803 two five
six I've received correspondence lovely
I have to declare an interest in British
gateway it's in my ward I'll be stepping
down and not chairing and asking vice
chair Molly Giles to chair that item and
I'll be speaking cancer I will be
stepping away for the table for the
first item London Southwest of Ulster
Road due to having previously expressed
comments in relation to that application
okay thank you
catcha bonds
[Music]
okay lovely so minutes of the last
meeting I they come through are we happy
with the minutes great lovely thank you
and do catch me later so we go straight
to the planning applications number four
land southwest of Ulster Road
stratford-on-avon and this concept thank
you chairman the application site which
is notated by the black dot in the
centre of the plan is on the western
edge of stratford-upon-avon adjacent to
shattering outline planning permission
was granted at a pier in 2012 for the
erection of up to eight hundred
dwellings this slide shows the
parameters plan which was approved under
this outline consent the application
before members this evening relates to
the area of the site outlined in red on
the slide the southern development area
phase one and seeks reserved matters
approval for appearance landscaping
layout and scale for 197 dwellings the
area of land outlined in dark blue
toward the north shows the location of
the two hundred dwellings which has been
given a resolution to approve and the
area of land outlined in light blue to
the west of that shows the area where
the remaining 400 dwellings would be
located a reserved matters application
for this part of the site has not yet
been submitted so turning to the
reserved matters before you this evening
this slide shows the application site
outlined in red the site is just outside
the conservation area which is denoted
by the solid pink line and a public
footpath lines the north boundary of the
site which denoted by the green dashed
line here the proposed layouts can be
seen in the context of the parameters
plan which was approved at outline stage
members will know the location of the
children's play area adjacent to the
northern boundary with incidental open
space along the eastern boundary the
public footpath along the northern
boundary would be retained in a green
corridor the west of sha teri relief
road which was approved through the
original outline consent
runs through the development pass or and
the black arrows denote approximate
locations for crossing points in
accordance with the approved design code
the layout proposes a dense formal
frontage along the main road with
densities decreasing towards Howorth
Road to the east of the site these
elevations give an impression of the
proposed Street seen to the eastern side
of the west of shotty relief Road as per
the design code the direct the dwellings
would be mainly red brick of two and
three stories and here's the streets in
elevation to the western side of the
west of shotty relief Road the apartment
building can be seen on the right-hand
side of the top of the plan here this
gives members an impression of the
street seen along the green edge of the
development to such units are proposed
to reflect the historic characteristics
of the town and they can be seen at
either side here two apartment buildings
are proposed one to the north of the
site and one to the west this plan shows
the building to the north as outlined in
yellow on the plan to the bottom corner
of the slide the building has been
broken up to appear as a row of
individual drawings and here the
elevations of the apartment building to
the west of the site again outlined in
yellow on the plan in the bottom corner
of the slide both apartment buildings
would extend to a height of 10 point 7
meters and I've just got a video to show
you so this slide here just shows where
I'm standing in taking the video so I'm
along the public footpath to the north
of the site here with obviously this
being the application site so this is
the public footpath looking to my right
looking in a westerly direction and
panning round you can see this is Borden
Hill in the distance here so basically
the light field is is where the
application site is so you can see the
buildings along yueshen Road at the end
there and then panning round to the back
of a ward front of dwellings on Hogarth
Road down there
and then back to the public footpath to
the north of the site
this goatee just shows the site from the
top of Borden Hill so again the lighter
colored field is the application site
here extends behind these buildings here
this building to be retained these to be
demolished with the access road punching
through here
and this slide shows some photographs
taken in a locality to show the style of
development which is found within
shorter e and a long evesham road and
hathaway lane there are some updates to
the application which are detailed in
the update sheet chairman the
recommendation is to approve this
reserved matters application subject to
planning permission being granted for
15/0 3 7 8 5 / vary which varies
conditions on the original outline
consent and subject to the conditions
detailed in the committee report and on
the update sheet thank you chairman
thank you very much we'll go straight to
speakers I think which is the Town
Council or council originally from
stratford-upon-avon Town Council who are
objecting mm-hmm and as you well know
you have three minutes and I'll give you
your two and a half warning I hope
[Music]
Thank You Jer oh but Donna this
development is at its most sensitive
entrance to a town where vistas of the
town has seen from the top of Borden
Hill where a comprehensive view of this
area has until now been a rule edge of
Warwickshire market town entrance with
hedges and waters the Town Council
believes that we should ensure through
sensitive planting that the edges of the
west aspect are softened to reflect this
characteristic of Bothnia market towns
fingering into the countryside not
presenting an urban gate rave and the
view from the top of Borden Hill to
present clusters of homes and nestling
between greenery sensitive tree planting
within the development can help by
placing two to three large trees towards
the center and smaller trees towards the
edges to give the observer a tree view
rather than roofs and chimneys this is
rising land at the edge of the town and
highly visible l-cysteine hedges should
be preserved or replanted once the
entrance and Ireland had been
constructed the Town Council is most
disappointed that despite
representations the developer has chosen
not to provide the housing mix which the
town knows it needs has compiled by the
housing needs survey which was done as
part of the NDP project which then led
to policies 86 and 87 of the NDP perhaps
the committee might like to ask the
developer why they've judged him to
disregard the needs of the town via
these policies the town council remains
disappointed at missed opportunities
following the appeal decision in 2012
and do believe that we should be mindful
of ensuring that our generation is seen
as having improved the standards of
development but the town counts are well
aware of the importance of this this
development within the five year land
supply so if you are mindful to grant
this application the Town Council would
request that at least the visual looks
of the development as mentioned
previously are included
thank you
thank you very much questions now from
the bond Council dawns 10% to bed 35%
three-bed 40% and 4 plus bed 15% and for
affordable one bed greater than 20%
greater or equal front of sent to bed
greater or equal to 40% 3 bed less or
equal to 35 percent and 4 plus bed less
or equal to 5% okay thank you and on
trees now I understand that the idea of
this development is to keep the the
edges somewhat sparse in a way to allow
pedestrian route through a green outer
edge which seems nice to me but of
course you don't get that that shielding
effect I mean so that's one thing to ask
you which you would prefer and second is
just to elaborate a little on these are
you talking about having more trees than
others quite a few trees planted in here
you talked about sort of feature trees I
think in specific locations fingers into
the into the rise of the hill I could
say Richard Gardiner is well aware of
this because this argument was used also
at the at the planning committee in 2010
11 or whenever it was and I felt it at
that particular at that particular time
the committee very in agreement with it
it should finger into the hillside you
mean stuff like landscaping yeah thank
you no further questions
thank you very much thank you so and our
next speaker we don't have any official
objectors so for the applicant the agent
justin wickersham who also has three
minutes and start when you wish good
evening my name is Justin Mukesh I'm
about to miss consulting I'm acting on
behalf of the applicant bovis Holmes
this application provides the details of
a development in relation to the
southern parcel that was granted consent
for up to 200 dwellings in the outline
permission this proposal provides 197
dwellings and is designed to a quarter
of the design code in all respects
furthermore the housing mix is in
accordance with the adopted policy for
the district the application has full
technical approval and there are no
objections from any of the 10th
constancies the planning officer has
given a recommendation for approval and
has provided a very detailed and
balanced assessment in her report the
applicant has always believed in the
importance of working with the Town
Council and board members acting on
behalf of their community since the
original submission of the reserved
matters application voters homes have
engaged with the community
representatives to consult on the
detailed design of the project through a
series of meetings this is allowed there
to be a significant improvement to the
overall quality of the project and work
and we commend the members for their
involvement and commitment to seeking
the best possible design solutions
for their community through this process
which began in 2017 the scheme has
evolved and we now have a design that
has an improved frontage to the Main
Street with railings and hedgerows the
introduction of to fact houses can key
locations within the development
improved elevation designed for the
apartment buildings that act as landmark
buildings improved highway design with
an improved parking strategy better
connectivity from east to west with four
crossing points over the Main Street
measures to reduce the speed limit to 30
miles an hour on the Main Street and 20
miles an hour within the development
oversized garages to meet modern vehicle
requirements and improved generous green
buff on the western boundary
introduction of natural play equipment
within the leap and improved housing mix
to meet the needs of the town and the
adopted policy to provide a range of
homes for all of the community we are
very grateful that the members that
represent their town their community
have been willing to meet with the
applicants throughout the design process
and provide honest and constructive
feedback we consider that the scheme is
now not only compliant with the design
code and the outline consent and the
adopted plan but it is also taken on
board the comments of design design
consideration that have been proposed
throughout the process of community
engagement we now have the full support
from the planning team and all technical
consequence Ortiz will be pleased to
receive a favorable determination from
your committee I'm happy to receive any
questions thank you very much are there
any questions
counted about three please the Town
Council said about the mix you say
you've had discussions but we're not
yelling or are we perhaps I can I can
best answer this in a couple of ways and
first and foremost the the design code
that is provided with the outline
application is a fairly and restrictive
basis
with that being part of an outlined
consent and this being a reserved matter
we are obliged to follow the design code
as as close as we possibly can so we've
worked very closely with officers and
technical companies to make sure that we
are meeting the design considerations
that were adopting the outline and
that's quite critical in understanding
how to density in the layout inside in
terms of the mix Germany when we first
started out on the planning journey we
inevitably started a level that was
significantly away from where we are now
and it's through the consultation
process that we've worked with the town
council and with officers to try and
change that mix to create more one and
to bed well ins within the proposals the
scheme was always intended we fear when
the original design concept was put
together for larger properties it could
be on the edge of a settlement and away
from the main term Center having said
that we have worked very close to try
and draw those levels together of course
over the time of the application
policies change matters move and
therefore the change has occurred and
with the neighbourhood develop plan also
providing its own housing and it mix
there has been an evolution through the
program but we have try to get as close
as we possibly can and we believe that
we've only brought this to committee or
being encouraged to boons to committee
because we've reached a level where it's
felt to officer level that we've now we
are now generally in conformity with the
housing mix policy within the adopted
plan burden development
[Music]
because I'm happy to take further advice
from the office on that's when my
understanding is that the proposals have
been put forward are considered
acceptable in technical terms with the
Highways Authority so the number of
crossing points the nature and design of
them is fulfilling the needs of the
highways or 'ti there is a slight
difficulty for is that the the Main
Street is defined through the outline
and therefore its its breadth and its
direction is something that is dictated
by the previous outlined consent so
working with that we've tried to improve
that the connectivity across that road
in particular to make sure there is the
opportunity with lower speeds to allow
people to cross given the nature we can
maybe go into that technical if we need
to okay any more questions thank you
very much can you yeah thank you and we
will go now to the ward member
councillor Morse
and you have five minutes counselor
thank you it's interesting to note that
outlying permission was given for this
site in 2009 ten years ago one of my
concerns about the site is that since
outline was agreed the traffic situation
has changed significantly we now have a
new road from the new settlement at long
last and joining up with the estate road
to take traffic to the a46 we will also
have the traffic from the planned
commercial estate at Athelstan airfield
so I am concerned chairman that before
long this estate root Road will prove
inadequate for the traffic it will have
to take in terms of design and width
chairman and there's increasing concern
about the impact of air pollution on
human health and you will have seen that
one of my original rejections was over
how close to the road some of the
proposed houses are just two weeks ago
the press was full of articles about
nights the National Institute for Health
and Care accidents a government advisory
body and their comments about the need
to address air pollution at the planning
stage and chairman if I can quote others
as it has been extensively referred to
in the press new houses should be kept
away from the roadside and planning
permission should be refused for
developments that do not mitigate air
pollution that members will see from the
layered map just how close are these new
houses will be - what - what will prove
to be a busy road carrying both cars and
lorries so I hope members will take that
into account in their ruminations
chairman and finally I have to
acknowledge that despite the comments of
the Town Council which I've got some
but the developers have proved very
helpful over housing mix and have
adjusted their initial plan
significantly to move the housing mix
the one that is a lot closer to the
council's core strategy from when they
began their sexercise I'm grateful for
that chairman I'm also grateful for the
fact of the developer's willingness to
take on board comments about design of
the properties and the been significant
changes to design over the period of
this application so again I'm grateful
for the consideration however that still
leaves the road problem both in terms of
design and closeness of some houses to
the road and that's obviously something
I hope members will consider when
reaching their decision tonight I would
also express my regret chairman the
District Council has not been prepared
to take up our request for early
compensation for some of the residents
in the area who will be affected by the
new development and the accompanying
Road Thank You Jamie thank you very much
any questions you've been very clear
counselor thank you very much so now we
get a questions to the officers counsel
wittich thank you so I've got two if I
may first of all the hard and soft
landscaping on to a third about the need
to have worthwhile soft landscaping I
think the phrase was fingering into the
Bourdon Hill our thought of the proposed
conditions are - about soft landscape
and one is the implementation of and one
is the replacement of can you first of
all explain to me what the difference is
between the implementation and
replacement I think I understand but I
just want to be clear and secondly have
we had a soft landscaping plan that you
can give us an idea of of how it would
actually look and what can be achieved
that's my first one yes of course that
we have had detailed landscape plans
submitted this layout plan if I can just
zoom in - it does represent
the plaque the tree-planting within the
site so you can see along here where
we've got the trees that's
representative of what's been submitted
on the detailed landscape plans that
they span about ten different plans
hence why haven't all got them here the
interesting thing with with this one is
that the buffer planting here because
that was a masa which was considered
outline it's actually conditioned
separately rather forming part of the
reserve matters so they have provided
detail on tree planting here but to my
mind that's indicative at this stage so
we've got under condition 37 of the
original outline consent
it requires details of that buffer
planting so if there's a specific sort
of expectation from members that this
should be particular species or numbers
in there then we have got a means by
which we can control that through the
discharge of that condition what I would
say and what I sort of pick up in the
report is I think they have increased
the the width of this by quite some
degree compared to what was submitted to
make sure we can get decent planting in
there but also we were quite keen to be
able to encourage this circular route
around the site so we don't necessarily
see it as being structural to the point
that we're trying to hide the
development will have a really thick
level of planting it's more that we can
have some good stature trees in that
soften the development but not hide it
because it's inevitable that you're
going to be able to see it and it's good
design so I don't see sort of an issue
with that and being able to create that
that circular route would in my view
create a nice pleasant environment for
future residents and locals who would
like to walk around it okay thank you I
was just going to say I didn't answer
the question on the different
implementation and yeah so the
implementation basically requires that
the landscaping details are submitted in
accordance with the landscape plans
which have been provided so that's that
it is planted when the development is
being built out the replacement is that
within a period of five years if any of
that planting fails there's an
obligation on the develops the developer
to replace that so that's the difference
between the two but clear okay good so
so the implementation of soft
landscaping is what we see there the
other stuff is condition deer
externalize
conditioned through the reserved matters
is it worth is adding that to this one
that at that same condition or are you
entirely happy that it's covered already
I'm happy unnecessary duplication to put
it on the reserve matters on content
that it got covered by the outlined
condition fine and they were suggesting
the housing nips and other policies
potentially from the NDP have been
ignored could you give us a view on or
give your view on that please so both
the call shastri policy and the NDP
policy required general accordance I
think it's preferred to mix in the core
strategy in general accordance in the
NDP in my view the mix as outlined to
think I've learned on pages 38 39 of the
agenda is in general accordance so to my
mind the housing mix does comply with
the NDP although it's not exactly in
accordance with the policy doesn't
require exact accordance it requires
general accordance and in my view it
does generally accord and therefore
complies thank you any other questions
I'm sorry we don't take questions from
the floor
councillor bars what see where the three
arrows are is on the left hand side how
close are they to the road it does look
to be on the right-hand side of the main
thoroughfare there will be trees well
that won't be allowed by the County
Council but what I was trying to find
out is how close are those so you're
interested to know how close these two I
guess the matter the back can't there
there's no driveway no driveways or
direct access isn't it onto the main
road so if I pick this is an example
because that's probably a bit of a pinch
point you're looking at a distance of
circa five metres to the edge as a foot
way and seven metres to the edge of the
carriageway sorry any other questions
catch storages Richardson the road
obviously there's a lot been said about
that both in the past and tonight I
think I know the answer this already but
just for clarity for myself but also for
the benefit of the other members if we
were just because there we know that
there is a wider plan to introduce
traffic from long Martin's along the
proposed Southwest relief Road and then
into this through this development given
we know that is there any way that we
can as a committee or as accounts or
insist that that road is essentially
future proofed and widened or are we
unable to do that the case officer for
the application for the road has
obviously had correspondence with the
various highways authorities and they're
satisfied with the width of the road
through the shot redevelopment is
sufficiently wide to take any additional
traffic which may is unvisited forward
if the southwestern relief road comes
forward so essentially there's no
requirement for it to be future proof
door to bust to safeguard additional
land to widen they're satisfied that
it's it's sufficient if we were to say
so tonight that we felt that that was
important is there every reason I reckon
rich is going to say what I already
think but is there a reason that that
that could be either appealed or removed
from as a condition from the consent in
terms of the the current proposal before
you it's governed by the outline
application which has detailed drawings
of the width of that road so it's not
within the gift of committee tonight to
revisit that
so this reserved matters can't change
the width of that Road so it's necessary
to determine what's before you but it's
not a planning consideration tonight to
change the width of the road if that was
the concerns members
no other questions okay arkinson the
earlier comments the count you were a
bit hesitant and I do see that on page
37 they have endorsed everything as far
as this application is concerned in
their responsibilities that was done
verbally I presume that has been
confirmed and they're quite happy with
every factor of road network with a new
development yeah so in accordance with
update sheet I received a consultation
response from highways yesterday raising
no objection to the principle of the
proposed layout subject conditions care
to organ thank you on page 26 there are
comments about refuse collection and I
wondered whether those had all been
resolved satisfactorily yes we received
amended plans following receipt of that
consultation response the 25 metres is
still approximately 26 metres but to my
mind generally Accord to the carry
distance and similarly the 10 metres is
11 metres so again one metre over and
we've had clarification and confirmation
on that the situation would have been
storing those plot numbers do we need a
break yard okay no more questions
[Music]
okay to debate will be any cancer bonds
not over keen on sort of 70 hours in the
block some three stories so as you can
see the rules are all different heights
so I suppose it doesn't look so bad
it is fairly close to the road obviously
there's been talk about affordability
and the respective design
I think it's better than I've seen in
other applications that we've had
previously but my concern is the road
and at the present time with the 680 as
he's coming to that island which is at
the end of this development coming down
and obviously we have to look I suppose
at the future possibilities where all
the trees will have to come out and my
concern is the road through there they
were a domestic semi-rural a part of
stratford-upon-avon to me is not good
any of comments counselor Richard Thank
You chair so okay some of what counts
the bans are set in terms of the design
actually it's quite refreshing to see
something that has had a appropriate
thought to it and even looking at what's
on our screen now that is more akin to
the style that one would expect in
Stratford and also the thatch cost
Article II of quite refreshing as well
to see snatched cottages so rare we see
that I'm it's a shame we have got more
of them in my opinion but enough work
has gone into the this is arrests he had
to enough work has gone into the rest of
the development for the ward member to
to actually thank that developers and
again that is very rare so from that
side I'm actually I am quite satisfied
the the road issue is you know it's a
concern but the sadly the reality and
what I thought I was going to get from
officers was we have if we're going to
insist on putting something a condition
of some sort through on that it has to
be reasonable and required for this
development well clearly the expansion
of that road is not required for this
development it's required for the
implementation of other developments I
think so my experience from from
planning appeals and and suchlike has
shown me that actually if we do put
something like that on we're likely to
have that appealed and then removed
anyway so our hands are kinda tied
the officers actually went one step
further and said that the road is
outside the scope of this planning
application so we really do have our
hands tied in this as far as the roads
concerns of what we're looking at really
is the housing and the design the
development the actual densities of that
we've heard that the mix fits our core
strategy is in general accordance same
with the neighborhood's development plan
really there's very little we can pin
our hat on to say actually do you know
what this isn't appropriate this is not
right and we should refuse it so with
that in mind and on that basis I will
propose that we do go with the offices
recommendation and approve okay thank
you I never got counselor Atkinson I
must say the design and the relief which
were sure is pleasant as far as I can
see I just can't see any problems at all
but what really does impact upon me is
that we've only had 12 letters of
objections from third parties that me
means residents they're a heck of lot
more people on the burgers row
internally house over 12 of hospital
system I think quite a good factor in
support of the application and I'm very
pleased to second councillor Richards
proposal would anyone else like I said
cast about so briefly I'm quite happy
with the proposal I wondered whether we
should have a note to say if any further
developments in the area consider the
road
I think Castle Richards has said there's
no point in doing that from the I
understand the sentiment but the
difficulty is we put a note on a
planning application that it's just is
saying if there's future development in
the area you need to widen the road was
unreasonable for us to insist that this
developer does that we'd have to do that
on any future developers Rakuten
we all know that each application should
be judged on its merits if any come in
then they will be dealt with that way
and the impact upon the overall
situation accordingly assess I think Jen
will go to that in a moment
thanks Rach Anderson I I quite
appreciate everyone's concern over the
road we have clear advice from County
Council and officers on that I would
like to stress the officers that if we
can if we can put any more you know
large major trees in this in this
development as suggested by the Town
Council to soften it within the actual
development and I'm thinking
particularly along that load to the
western side of the road there seems to
be very few trees there's plenty on the
east but not on the west and and trees
do help from a pollution point of view
as well so the more trees we can get in
there and I don't see why why we
shouldn't to break up the mass there
from a view from Borden Hill the better
that said we shall go to the voters oh
we have additional conditions from
highways which are on the update sheet
so as they're all those in favor of
granting okay so this committee has
resolved to grant planning permission
for 1600 7:37 I am and just before I go
on to the next application I'll just
point out that in my letter to the
committee there is a typo I'm sorry
about that in the bottom second bottom
paragraph when it says also routes to
Tewkesbury which is ten minutes longer
it should read also games I don't think
you should be reading that from the
chair
you should be doing that when you're sat
at the board members table it's too late
counselor I've just read it but now I
shall remove myself from the chair and
let Molly Charles take over
committee will now deal with application
1803 746 very and in relation to the
redditch gateway and i invite miss
cosmic to make the presentation Thank
You chair
this application proposes variations to
conditions attached to the previously
approved application 17 / 0 1 8 4 7 /
out members resolved to grant this
application on the 31st of January 2018
and after completion of the legal
agreement the decision notice was issued
on the 11th of June 2018 this earlier
application gave outline consent for 32
hectares of employment land for business
and industrial uses and full consent for
the creation of the first development
Plateau
and access to the site from Coventry
Highway the principle of development has
therefore been accepted and the
application before members this evening
seeks to make changes to the parameters
of development for the northern
development parcel and first development
plateau the application site as
identified by the black dot in the
center of the plan is located on the
edge of the built-up area of Redditch
the site as outlined in red is allocated
for employment development under
policies red one and red two of the core
strategy the application site falls
within the jurisdictions of
stratford-on-avon district council
reddish borough council and Bromsgrove
district council three identical
applications have been submitted to each
authority the green dots on the plan
show the approximate locations of the
four veteran oak trees proposed for
relocation and the yellow stars shown
nearby listed buildings the location of
the black sewers Brook is also indicated
on the plan this application seeks to
amend the parameters of development for
the northern development parcel which is
the area of the site to the north of the
Coventry Highway the approved and Perot
proposed parameters plans can be seen
here the approved parameters plan
includes five employment zones for four
buildings ranging in height from nine
meters to 20
meters and 1/4 parking so to clarify
that's on the left-hand side of the plan
the proposed plan itis plan is shown on
the right-hand side of the slide it
proposes for employment zones just the
1/4 buildings with a maximum height of
16 point 5 meters as indicated by the
yellow shading and 3/4 parking as
indicated by the gray shading on the
plan as members will note from the two
parameters plans the area for green
infrastructure on proposed parameters
plan has been increased incorporating an
area to the southeast corner of the
northern development parcels so that's
this area here as well as previously
approved landscape buffer adjacent to
Gorka Hall no changes are proposed to
the southern development parcel so
that's this area here here the
previously proposed alliterative master
plan can be seen on the left-hand side
of the slide with a now proposed master
plan on the right-hand side of the slide
due to the reduction in a number of
employment zones for buildings the built
form has been consolidated into a single
building with car parking to its east
and enlarged areas of green
infrastructure black salzburg can be
seen on the previously proposed master
plan this would be diverted as you can
see indicative Lea around here to allow
for the larger employment zone on the
proposed parameters plan and master plan
again no changes are proposed to the
southern development parcel the full
element includes the ground works
associated with creating the first
development platform which would have
banking to its perimeter the full
element of the scheme includes the means
of access from Coventry Highway which
remains unchanged to that previously
approved I now have a video to show
members so the white star here indicates
where I was standing in taking that
video and it's basically panning around
the Northern Development pass or so I've
got the main Coventry highway behind me
here and we're panning around looking in
northerly direction but the woodland
there and the existing Ravens Bank
industrial park here
and then back toward the commentary
highway members should note that there
are a number of updates of the
application as detailed within the
update sheet chair the recommendation is
to grant the application subjects of
conditions detailed in the committee
report and update sheet Thank You chair
if we could now call our first speaker
miss Len courtly to address the
committee you from the from when you
start you'll have three minutes and if
you'd like to just push the button in
the middle microphone yes what on who
I'm representing on representing three
bodies one is Winnie H green residents
Association
another one is Malibu green parish
council for which Missy Berry is one of
the parish councils and also nothing
would agree in school for which mrs.
Barry is chair of Governors thank you
okay the potential occupier for this
site is unknown and there is no evidence
to support their statement that the
majority of traffic will travel north
and indeed significant amount of traffic
will go south yet the planning law seems
to fly in the face of open government by
allowing you to approve this application
for a massive distribution center in a
vacuum the proposed HGV routing strategy
which is intended to protect mappable
green and studly is yet to be agreed
with many questions to be answered about
the effectiveness of the monitoring and
enforcement processes should the
potential or subsequent occupier require
their distribution to gravitate south
the proposed
HGV routing strategy will certainly fail
bringing further misery from Mapple
Barry green studly and
on the April 3-5 through coating the a
435 is already considered to be a
problematical road and the obstinate
claim is true that the majority of the
traffic from the site will go north can
only add to those problems especially at
the junction with the motorway the
junction on the a 402 through a Coventry
highway to be used by HGVs accessing and
exiting and exiting the north side is
approximately 100 metres from wing H
green housing the impact from noise
light and air pollution from diesel
HGTV's stopping and starting will be
substantial and that's before any
application for development on the south
side is considered ecologically we are
very disturbed and very concerned about
the obliteration of black soils Brook an
ancient brook and its associated
hedgerow as well as other damage to the
local environment if you approve this
application it must not be seen as the
thin end of the wedge to approve any
subsequent full application which must
be scrutinized much more carefully than
current planning law appears to allow
for this application before you in any
event we understand that no decision can
be made by you tonight as Bromsgrove
Planning Committee has left the
decisions in the hand of their chair
Thank You chairman any questions
committee councillor bonds
[Music]
if I could now invite councillor Beeman
to address Committee on behalf of Dudley
Parish Council thank you thank you Jeff
Thank You members here again I'm looking
through some papers today I found a plan
that was we discussed that in his
council chamber in 2013 but this was
first discussed and this is such an
important decided actually feet which is
really heavily in our core strategy I
say air core strategy because these
errors and this application flies
directly against what is stated in that
core strategy and that is something that
I have real concern over if we are
actually going to allow something that
is contrary to what is an air core
strategy it opens the gates for a lot of
other applications what we're looking to
do is to change what was approved which
is a minimum of 15 percent floor retail
floor space cuss womb' office and Class
B research and development use into one
distribution warehouse that flies
against the reason for taking this out
of the green belt and permitting it was
to provide a mix of employment
opportunities and provide readily needed
in Redditch that research and
development opportunities which this
will remove from there one of the other
things air core strategy is to protect
important natural features on the site
and retain mature hedgerows along the
western boundary
again what this application is seeking
to do is to rip out an ancient head row
ed row and a watercourse that has been
there for hundreds of years probably
even longer than that just to make it
fit so if I can get a great big
warehouse in the middle where this is
going to be is visible from the whole of
the basin of rediff and suddenly when
you drive into Studley and you drive
into it if you come down the hill
whichever way you come and this is going
to be stuck up on the hill and it's
going to you
proline din obvious to everybody there
are will be issues from lighting because
it's hot and visibility is going to be
seen from most of the town we can't
control but I see one of the reports is
questioning the the lighting that is
being proposed and I think that needs to
be really carefully controlled I trust
their offices to keep an eye on that but
I think the issues that I think that we
can we you could opt actually object on
this or the destruction of the natural
habitat the loss of the hedgerows and
the loss of the employment opportunities
and the development uses but to me is a
country to our core strategy and that is
justification in itself to oppose the
other one we have is HTV routine that
isn't part of this application but this
committee saw it really wise to put a
condition on that the HTV thirty-seconds
HTV routine strategy was approved before
any further permissions were this went
ahead that route in strategy has still
not been approved and I had members on
that committee and I am very concerned
at what is being proposed I don't see it
working and modu many of the members on
that committee so members ask you to
look very carefully before you approve
this thank you thank you
councillors any questions no Thank You
council even thank you if I could now
call the agent mr. rouse all right is it
mouse
thank you you have six minutes thank you
Jeff
good evening chairman and committee
members the application before you is a
variation of a planning permission
granted by this council in June 2018 the
principles of the development have not
changed this application simply seeks
amendments to enable particular occupier
requirements to be met which cannot be
met by any other site or building the
changes relate to the site north of the
Coventry Highway only there are no
changes to the site south of the
Coventry highway enabling that occupier
to locate at the site will deliver
significant investment and job creation
for the local area on Monday this week
Bromsgrove District Council resolved in
unanimously to support an identical
application for the significant area of
the site within its administration the
planning application proposal Accords
generally with the strap on Aven core
strategy allocation and will deliver the
planned development the need for
strategic employment sites in this area
is underlined by the significant public
investment by was to share a local
enterprise partnership and Holmes
England to bring this site forward
Worcestershire lap has concluded that
there are no alternative sites all
buildings which can meet the occupier
requirements and that this proposal is a
game changer as they quote for the local
economy this application does not
substantially change the extant of
planning permission importantly the
amount of floor space proposed is
unchanged the use class is unchanged and
that includes the level of b1 office
floor space which is remains unchanged
from the current extant and permission
the amount and type of traffic that will
be generated is also unchanged
there are accordingly no objections from
either workshare or Worcestershire
highway authorities there are however
important changes the concentration of
building into a single development zone
on
the site moves the building
substantially out of Stratford district
a substantial new area of conservation
landscape will reduce the impact on the
setting of cork at Hall compared with
the extent permission the height of the
building will also be reduced which will
reduce further further reduce a visual
impact this is achieved by reduction in
the ground-level height of the
development zone with the exception of a
small area in the southwest corner and
the maximum height of buildings is also
reduced from 21 meters to sixteen point
five this results in a lower maximum top
of building height across the whole
development area in Stratford district
the HTV routing strategy required by
conditioned on the current planning
permission which prevents HGVs rooting
through map of green or studly will
remain unchanged the routing strategy
has been consulted upon with the
steering group comprising officers and
the parish councils and will be
submitted for formal approval as a
discharge of condition approval of this
application will result in additional
new and retained hedgerow additional
brook watercourse
additional ponds an additional area of
grassland over the current planning
permission and no change to traffic
levels or routing your officers conclude
the proposal is a sustainable
development and that it Accords
generally with the development plan
benefits outweigh any harm and the
application is recommended to you for
approval thank you
counselors any questions counselor
Barnes I was just going to ask about the
school cropsy is your development going
to make the road worse in the respective
I think I asked you before there was
some talk there is no pedestrian
crossing proposed but I think the two
Highway Authority consultation responses
that you have that there are no
objections provide the confirmation that
you seek that there is not a highway
safety problem Thank You councillor
Richards thank you
you mentioned landscaping and additional
bushes and trees and bits and pieces it
seems to me that the main area of trees
that was on the approved plan straight
through the middle it's completely
disappearing and I can't see anywhere
where that's being replaced on your new
plan your proposed plan can you talk me
through through its ones done yes so
just no doubt blanc sauce brook the
majority of blacks halls broad cache
line does get removed under this
application however if you work your way
further right there are two because of
the parking strategy we've chosen to
design up we're retaining - hedgerows
which would have been removed under the
original outline planning so you are you
doing this direction so you see that
hedgerow there and there's a one further
if you go to the employment zone on the
right-hand side there's another hedgerow
which will continue through that will
continue through so those ancient
headline hedgerows were to be removed
under the original outline are now going
to be retained under this new outline so
there is some compensation and then
furthermore we now have a lot more green
space to offset more hedgerow so we're
looking to double the amount of
hedgerows which we are removing with new
hedgerows and the parking facilities a
you providing the same level of parking
as you were before
giving you the same level of employment
London yes so there is less parking is
475 spaces that go with this one
building and that is meets the local
planning policy for parking levels can I
just clarify the this is an outline what
is a hybrid application so the element
that largely that we're looking at here
is in outline the only full element is
the phase one plateau for ground
engineering works so at this stage the
levels of parking are not defined and
they're not a set for approval so there
is no change to proposal from previously
in relation to the level of parking to
the level of floor space but the reality
is were likely to based on what we've
just heard well we're here today with
the proposed changes because we have a
specific occupier and because we want to
bring that forward in the early course
so yes what you've just heard relates to
the specific occupy requirement that we
have no thank you could I just take your
name for the record sorry
yes Alex Morgan thank you thank you very
much and if I could now invite
councillor courage to speak
thank you oh five minutes you have five
minutes
so just first of all I've just been
handed a copy of some brief notes from
the from the planning committee from
Bromsgrove which are signed by the chair
the final sentence being the
applications accepted subject to the
ecological matters being addressed in
consultation with the chair so it has
been agreed by Brahms as not as it
matters to us but they are going to
consult on ecological matters and I'm
told that the chair is also arranged to
meet with some of the objectives we've
heard tonight to discuss issues as well
that's just to clear that up so I mean
I've put my points down on the on the
update sheet a lot of them refer to the
next stage which will be the reserved
matters it is incredibly important that
those reserved matters are strongly
scrutinized especially around lighting
into the woods and lighting eastward to
the a for 3/5 and the views from there
and beyond especially about design it's
a huge shed
it's a massive I really I can only think
of things along the M the M 40 to
compare it to so you know we're going to
notice it so design will matter color
will matter how the how the roof is
colored how the roof is designed and the
the equipment that will be on the roof
is is hidden or designed so well these
are reserved matters not tonight I admit
but they it's just really important that
this goes goes forward carefully if it
is approved tonight and secondly to
touch on routing HGV routing especially
I know what we see before us is the
worst
case scenario as far as a ward member
goes I mean we were all hoping for
something like aerospace or or something
high-tech and we have 121 Laurie lawyers
coming in and out God knows how many
times a day this is the worst number of
HGTV's we could have hoped for
and I know you'll be told that that's
already been accounted for in in the
County Council's considerations it is
it's it's just it's not what we wanted
it's definitely not what we wanted it's
not what was envisaged when we granted
this when it was planned when it was put
into our policy this was exactly not
what we wanted be eight you know over
the life of the development we've got
more and more be a sort of accepted from
sort of pragmatism and and now we're
ending up with with all be eight as far
as I can see so if it is to be granted
the the HTV routing strategy has to be
absolutely signed and I believe what we
have got is pretty good but it doesn't
take a count and we didn't take account
and it's our fault of further down the
line we've got studly in a map of a
green safe but we didn't consider cotan
we didn't consider king coat and Kings
codon which are the stretches of the a
45 below steadily where the HTV route
stops and then it continues on the 8:45
done to the a46 now I've put in my
report that there are alternative routes
for almost everywhere whether it be
Stratford and ships trim whether it be
Worcester or Tewksbury and the m5 and
the m-40 there's no need to use this but
it might be used and and I would like to
find some way to avoid that I can't sit
here and tell you what that is but I
would like some effort some serious
effort made by this council and the kind
council to find an even better solution
than the one we have at the moment what
that is I really wish I could say but
maybe somebody can come up with
something that needs to go in as a
strong message thank you Thank You
council as any questions no Thank You
councillor courage councillors if can't
wait to make any technical questions of
the officers councillor Richard thank
you very much we've heard a lot about
the HTV routing and etc that doesn't
form part of this application does it
it's it's part of the previous one it's
already modeled on a worst case scenario
and the highway authorities have
confirmed that the section 73 change
wouldn't material impact on the highways
impacts which has already been
considered and found to be acceptable
subject conditions including the HTV
route and strategy if I can ask I think
there's something raised on page 56
about public right-of-way can I can I
just check there aren't any issues in
relation to that little bit of ambiguity
in some of the objections raised I think
it's actually Worcester County Council
Highway says applicant needs to be aware
of its obligations towards the public
right-of-way yes of course
so at present there's a public
right-of-way which runs along the black
soils Brook in about this location so
basically they would need to apply to
divert in diverse and a black source
Brook and they provided an indicative
kind of comes around like this they have
been consulted nopsi I know the
applicants of the applications in motion
to get those sorted until the diversions
are allowed essentially they wouldn't be
able to close the public footpath as it
stands at the moment so the only point
that that would close would be when they
have got the relevant diversion
permissions from the relevant
authorities I take it that's conditioned
in terms of securing that order of
it's covered by separate legislation in
terms of diversion of the public
right-of-way so they couldn't do it
under that legislation so any condition
which is duplicate it so reading about
the because obviously one of the issues
about the brook is it it's a it's a
physical representation of the
potentially ancient county boundary
lines it have historical relevance I
note in the report that it's it's been
said that some mitigation measures may
be out not just in terms of because
obviously it's going to be routed the
brook but the issue is how do we then
mark that as as you know give it some
historical significance and keep that
there and I think there's some
suggestion in the report that there are
some things some physical things that
could be done to try to at least mark
that I'm just wondering what what you
might be driving at and what those might
be yes I mean to my mind if we had two
very different opinions from the
applicant and then from Webster County
Council and archeology team and the
applicant arguing that the county
boundary will remain unchanged
essentially but obviously was Tisha's
view is that we are losing those
physical markers so to my mind if we can
keep some sort of physical marker there
then it lessens the harm and we were
thinking whether there was any scope to
retain some of the hedgerow in this
location here potentially to keep that
marker and then even just a structure of
some form and even a line on the floor
down here something like that to show
that it is the the location of the
historic county boundary and things like
sign boards potentially to give
information that that is what was
previously there these marks to note
that historic boundary to my mind would
lessen the result in harm from losing
that historic marker
um on page 60 wish was to share wildlife
trust raised that they're concerned that
the changes of conditions allow for
vegetation clearance in advance of other
conditions being charged discharged I
just wonder if you could expand on that
I mean is that the proposal the this
what we're being asked to look at
actually allows a lot of the vegetation
clearance even those we haven't fully
signed off all of the other conditions
in some instances they have asked for
clarifications and slight tweaks to
conditions to allow hedge reven tree
removal for example and the
archeological conditions where they can
go ahead and start the trial trenching
and investigations they can do that
sorry they can do that after they've
removed the hedgerow and tree removal
does that make sense so there's no sort
of impact by allowing that tree and
hedgerow removal on the archaeological
deposits so there are a few conditions
and I think they're detailed on within
the description of development actually
which does allow for that Headroom tree
clearance prior to coming into effect of
that condition but that's being
considered throughout and the impact is
considered to be acceptable in terms of
we still have control over ensuring that
ecology matters are still safeguarded
and you'll note that there's a new
condition on the update sheet regarding
a biodiversity construction environment
to a management plan and that's to make
sure that any sort of environmental
impact an ecological impact from tree
and hetero removal can be picked up and
safeguarded through that I suppose my
anxieties and what I'm driving at is is
there a possibility that for example
there's extensive hedgerow and
vegetation clearance and then for some
reason because I mean it's unlikely but
because some significant condition can't
be discharged the site can't come
forward but then you've just in this
manner and you've unnecessarily taken
out hedgerow that can't be replaced in
terms of so if I pick this up so in the
previous application so if we look at
the approved parameters plan there are a
number of hedgerows which were approved
for a removal through through this
consent but in order to not require an
application to a hedgerow notification
there needs to be full consent for the
removal so outline isn't enough so for
these where we accepted the removal of
the hedgerows outline stage they then
had to come in separately for a hedgerow
notification so they could take those
out prior to bird nesting seeds and
starting at the beginning of March so
what I would say in terms of obviously
that's already been accepted the
additional header which is being removed
is the main one along this practice or
was broke even if we grant the outline
consent although it's hybrids that
outline only relates to this area here
they wouldn't have the full permission
necessary to be able to take out that
hedgerow without having to go through
the hedgerow notification regs
so it's either we have a reserve matters
which approves the detail to the point
where those hedgerows can come out or
they have to go through the hedgerow
notification so we've got it's not like
if we grant this they can go in tomorrow
and remove that hedgerow they can remove
the ones where they've got consent
through the head or a notification
already but they wouldn't be able to
remove that without first having the
reserve matters in place or by applying
through the hedgerow removal regs so
there is basically what you're telling
me is there is that additional oversight
before any hedgerow can be removed to
see whether that's it's being done at
the right time finally understand thank
you very much I think that's it from me
thank you can open it the matter to
debate champs Laban's remember the
inspector and with great concern
everybody there that the roads weren't
suitable so I'm a business park bear
Worcestershire said that the roads were
all right and we've moved on once or
twice keeper at once and as far as I'm
concerned them I think the reason for
the variation is obvious and I'm happy
with the the recommendation and the qua
deputy proposed it so people have
building houses they've got somewhere to
work well there are some comments I'd
like to make
I mean it's obvious that in some ways
this application does cause more harm
than when we looked at it you know some
very valid points have been made in very
detailed observations by console T's
about you know the bulk and the mass of
this building but it is fat and and to
me I do think that the removal of the
hedgerow you know that middle line that
counter boundary that's you know it's
it's another harm there are some
improvements and benefits those that
come with it and it is in that green
increased green buffer and Gorka hall is
at that end so there is potentially some
betterment so in some ways it's a bit of
a balance and I'll get the impression
from some of the console T's they sort
of say well you know it's worse in some
ways and better in some ways and it sort
of equals itself out really I completely
sympathize with the frustration about
people about traffic because in a way to
be told this is for this is it falls
within the worst case scenario and we've
already modelled for it it's of no
comfort and I I would like to endorse
what councillor carriages said which is
that if there is ongoing work in
relation to the traffic management plan
there's got to be some really serious
consideration given to the to the risks
around what this site is now going to be
used for the fact that it is going to
have heavy a lot of extra heavy traffic
use and that's got to be taken into
account during that process it's just
very frustrating for a committee that we
don't actually have the power to do
anything about that however I've been
through the comments and the notes and
what I I would like to suggest to
committee if committee would agree to it
is that we place a note alongside if if
this committee decides to approve the
application the that firstly proper
discussion takes place in terms of the
HGV routing plans given the nature of
the the employment site that's proposed
but then also in particular I would say
that committee wishes for particular
attention to be given in the discharge
of conditions and a reserved matters
stage
to the lighting plan a number of console
tees of raised issues about it and at
the moment it's not satisfactory they're
concerned about spill in two important
areas particular tension is given to
levels and making sure the woodland
adjacent to the northern boundary is
protected making sure that any ways that
we can mitigate harm in general to the
landscape and to the listed building as
councilor carriage referred to in terms
of design color of building roof
lighting materials this is going to have
a huge impact on the surrounding area
and I think and in my in my opinion I
hope committee would agree with this
it's incumbent upon the applicant to
work really really hard to try to reduce
those harms and I would like to see some
creative solutions to properly mark the
loss of that historic County boundary
line because I agree with the most
archeology comments that actually it is
a loss and it's a significant historical
loss physical features are important in
helping us understand our our history
and I think you know it can be something
quite elegant it could be aligned
through the site with some explanatory
material and I think that would be quite
nice so I would like to not add those
things as a condition but just a note
that in committee and in approving this
application if it wishes to would like
those things to be given attention so I
don't know in your proposed accounts the
bonds whether it whether you're happy
for that to be added I think the issue
is a lot of those things in fairness are
either already part of conditions or
very much to be addressed reserve matter
stage and I suppose it's about saying
it's this early flag when this comes
reserve come at is certainly in terms of
this local authority we do want to pay
great attention to those things and this
isn't just going to be oh yeah wave
through we could Evernote about the
school if you like as well if you want
to add something to your proposal people
vote on it for that yes and I'm fully
support what you've said clarify counts
of bounds suggested know about the
school what what what do we want to say
about the school that we there's been
more traffic going past the school does
appear that all the children live on one
side of the road and the school is on
the other side of the road she had been
brought up by the lady before and the
developer said it was the County Council
or either or both I just feel that we
should ever know if this show air
concern so we're waiting for a child to
be killed and then do something
counselor Richards thank you I support
you the sentiment of your note
I believe it's already covered under
note three through the the steering
group a lot of what you've raised will
be covered by the act
it also does specific please talk about
the HTV routing strategies which is I
think what we've got to the HDTV
strategy that has been proposed and my
suggestion would be if you do want to
add other specifically names I think it
was the lighting scheme and hedgerows
that we add lighting scheme and hedgerow
so that couldn't that note and then
we've already covered everything I've
been I've used if all of that list I
won't repeat it he's added into that
paragraph yeah I don't have a problem
with that if that's possible
yeah all the matters there that the
minister can be incorporated in a note
on any planning permission thank you
don't have a seconder for councillor
Barnes is amended proposal councillor
Richards great thank you
and then if I could turn counters update
sheets the update sheet there's a
suggestion of three additional
conditions and submission and approval
of the veteran tree strategy approval of
the biodiversity construction
environment management plan and
design for the realignment of the black
soils Brook I take it you're happy for
those conditions to be added in thank
you okay if I could ask all those in
favor of the proposal to grant the
application unanimous chair this
committee therefore resolves to grant
application 18 / zero three seven four
six very five-minute break
so thank you ladies and gentlemen if we
could just introduce our two replacement
planning offices thank Jeff fresh off
the substitutes bench I'm Dale Barker
I'm taking over as manager of the
committee from Richard on exactly the
same terms as he will have explained to
you at the beginning of the meeting and
this is three school and Senior Planner
and we are looking at application land
north of Alamo Lane and if you can lead
us into that Louise Thank You chair the
application site is identified by the
black dot on the map and it's located in
an area of land which is situated on the
western edge of Ulster town outline
Planning Commission for the erection of
160 dwellings has already been granted
where the means of access approved the
application before members as evening is
for reserved matters with appearance a
landscape and layout and scale to be
considered the site identified by the
red line in the plan is an allocated
site known as al c2 which falls within
the built a barrier boundary of Ulster
the site joins existing residential
development which abuts part of the
eastern boundary the a45 bypass a lot
but joins the western boundary and
agricultural land lies to the south the
land to the south of the site is also an
allocated site known as al c1 and has
outlined consent for the erection of up
to one hundred and ninety dwellings
accessed of eclipse Road in is also
subject to a current reserved matters
application a public footpath runs
across part of the site running in a
north western direction and exiting onto
the bypass
the site comprises of 6.42 hectares of
land and surrounded and its boundaries
by mature tree and hedgerow planting
this includes substantial planting on
the highway embankment abutting the a
435 bypass along the western boundary
the site contains a number of trees
subject to tree preservation orders
along the southern boundary the longest
vicinity here and here the layout other
proposals has been revised during the
course of the application and largely
accord to the principles of the approved
design code access to the site involves
a new vehicle a junction with ghost
right-hand turning lane and pedestrian
crossing a 1.8 meter wide foot way would
also be provided and a new foot way
linking the access with the existing
foot way which currently stops south of
Roebuck Park within the site a main
access road is proposed which runs in a
north-south direction leading to
secondary drives and private roads the
road runs right to the Sun boundary to
allow direct connectivity with a
residential development coming forward
into the separate Preserve matter
application for local areas of play are
proposed together with areas of open
space and the dwellings are proposed to
be orientated to face onto these areas
allowing natural surveillance to occur -
attenuation swales are proposed in the
in a north-south axis along part of the
eastern part of the site with open space
surrounding these areas and a footpath
proposed along the eastern boundary a
landscape buffer is also proposed along
the western boundary
a leap is also proposed in the
southwestern corner of the site with
footpath surrounding allowing linkage
into the open space areas proposed as
part of the land to the south of Alamo
Lane and the separate reserved matter
application in terms of elevations the
design of the dwellings has been revised
during the course of the application
following negotiations with offices in
response to comments from consul tees a
mix of two three so one two three and
four
begged Wellings are proposed with 35%
affordable the dwellings are also
proposed to be two-story with the
exception of two bungalows the design in
form of the proposed dwellings draw upon
the local vernacular and would be
constructed primarily a brick who the
users and wrens are in contrasting roof
tiles the ridge heights are very to
provide greater interest within the
street scene turn into photographs this
is a view showing the location of the
new vehicle access
sorry go back to that one along the
berming Road looking in a northerly
direction the access is where the arrows
are shown then this is a view looking
from the a 435 bypass show in the
embankment and tree planting which is
existing
turning now I have a couple of videos oh
yeah thank you right this is a view
within the site actually I've been there
long way around this is a view from the
middle part of the site looking along
the western boundary I am just zooming
in here is two of the TPO trees there in
the southern corner which are proposed
to be retained together with this tree
here the access which is proposed to
link into the southern part of the site
would be located than this vicinity here
then I'm looking along here which is the
just outside of the site there's the
existing public footpath route which we
obviously maintained together with this
existing tree planting so this is where
the swales would also be located within
this vicinity this is looking at the
northern part of the site northernmost
spot corner looking around this is the
western boundary where the bypass is
situated beyond those embankment entries
again looking towards the South southern
part the other area of sorry be an
extraneous rail be located here this
existing tree planting is retained
these are the residential properties at
robic Park and then this is the return
on to the Birmingham Road with a robot
curb here where the existing accesses
are proposed to be removed and hydro
reinstated a recommendation sorry
there's two updates contained within the
update sheet to note and the
recommendation is to approve the reserve
masters subject to the conditions and
notes as detailed in the report
thank you very much great so we should
go to town council representative
professor councillor v Neil Sturgis for
Ulster Town Council who are objecting
and you have three minutes as you
probably well know good evening everyone
firstly on behalf of the planning
committee to the case officer a
constructive approach and a
comprehensive report and to the
developers for working with both
yourselves and us coming towards an
acceptable scheme and for also providing
a representative at latest public
consultations so the first version of
the plans we have 23 concerns due to
extensive background work - t sender
developers that was reduced to 12 issues
in the second version of plans and we
now have six residual concerns which are
with Riaan councillor Adams will deal
with arrest the first concern with site
layout plan shows it's not shown on any
of the videos we've seen but the
majority of the affordable houses are
still mostly along the boundary with the
a4 3/5 which is an issue which has have
been of concern all the way through
although the developers of again
addressed this point in the late most
recent documents in our view it is still
not particularly acceptable
we would like a much more even
distribution of affordable properties it
seems that the affordable properties are
being used partly as a noise pond
the second unrelated issue is in policy
I also a lc2 says a substantial
landscape buffer is required which is
indeed shown on the plans but in no
great detail and we're just concerned
and would request an additional
condition that a buffer width of at
least three meters be maintained along
the entire western boundary the final
point I'd like to make is a drainage
system including the swales which were
as the operators pointed out have been
extensively modified in this version
there are two trails this is a northern
application the other half of this
development is a certain part but we
haven't seen the resume yet thirty
seconds left
yes it is a large development it will
take up to seven years we would just ask
there is a condition that the full flood
mitigation on both sides should be
completed in phase one of the
development because the bottom site the
South's bottom of the South site is
where the major flooding concerns occur
and if the drainage is allowed to sit
down to the bottom of that site it'll
still be problems thank you okay thank
you good your time is up
are there any questions nope thank you
very much very thank like clear now we
go to Andrew Winstone and Nick Rawlings
from blow homes
welcome and you have three minutes
however you wish to use them I'll tell
you what two and a half Thank You chair
my name's Andrew Winstone from poor
homes my colleague Nick Rawlings we're
pleased to see the Lord service
application for all housing proposals on
its allocated site is recommended for
approval as indicated in the report we
have had a number of meetings with
district bound county council officers
and the tank Council to discuss and
improve and improve the details of the
scheme as a result we have made a
significant number of changes to the
layout to address all run on policy and
technical issues raised into
consultation responses we are pleased to
note that the officers report confirms
the proposed dwellings will achieve a
good quality design that would be
appropriate in this location and that's
overall the proposals represent
sustainable development of which should
be approved more homes a private family
company has delivered a number of high
quality developments in the district now
we are committed to bringing forward the
very best of and possible on this site
we are aware that the Town Council
continues to have some concerns with our
proposals and we are pleased to see that
the addressed
quite a large number of those and we
also note that these are fully addressed
in the officers report in particular we
note the concern that our northern area
site is proceeding ahead of the southern
parcel which is in separate control
however we want to emphasize that the
north and south areas are identified and
allocated as separate albeit contiguous
residential development sites in the
adopted core strategy they are also in
also an important part of its developed
strategy in terms of timely housing
delivery as advised in the officer's
report condition 25 of the outline
permission does not require the approve
the reserved matters details for both
the north and south areas to be granted
at the same time the approved design
code allows both site both sites to be
developed independently with an
undertaking that a contiguous
north-south Main Street link was
delivered to achieve the comprehensive
development of both
areas on drainage that the lead local
flood authority has confirmed that
raises no objections to our proposals
and has clarified that the application
site acts independently from the
southern side in terms of drainage
further the design details of both sites
have been shared between Bloor and the
applicants of the southern area and
discussed at the meetings with officers
this is to ensure joined-up approach is
taken two key considerations such as
built form relationships strategic
landscaping open space and connectivity
your office's report concludes that our
proposals as amended and improved the
core and improved Accord with the
parameters previously approved at the
outline stage and you have under 30
second G in all other respects we were
therefore very much welcomed or support
for application today thank you thank
you very much any questions from the
counselors no again very clear thank you
very much and we now call on councillor
Adams as the ward member who have five
minutes if you wish it thank you mr.
chairman thank Ancestors has said I'd
like to echo his words in fact the case
officer for all her work involving the
Town Council in meetings with the
developer and coming up with this very
acceptable scheme I would like the
committee's help in addressing some of
the concerns that we feel are still
outstanding the plan and show a
pedestrian refuge to be constructed on
the Birmingham Road opposite the
northern entrance to the site this is
very welcome but it must be in place to
ensure that there is a safe route to
schools once the site is occupied this
is a very busy road especially at school
times and it gets and to get through any
of the schools in Ulster you must cross
this road I would like to see condition
imposed that the refuge should be
completed before the occupation of the
first dwelling
and the public footpath al 50b crosses
the site and I would also like to say
condition that they thought path was
kept open unobstructed at all times
during the construction period this is a
prominent sight visible from many points
in Oslo this skiing is only acceptable
if the houses are kept to two storeys
unlimited to nine meters in height
whilst the plans show only two-story
houses there should be a condition
confirming that the houses will be no
more than two storeys with the maximum
size of nine meters to ensure that there
is no amendment sought after a later
date finally since the outlying planning
consent was granted in 2014 it is now
likely that some children will have to
see from the development will have to
attend the primary school at cotan the
layout of the roads that they'll have to
cross at the industrial states have
changed and across he may be required we
appreciate that the access issues of
this planning application were dealt
with at the outlying stage and haven't
lag be considered but could we please
act as SDC's support in future
negotiations with WCC highways that's
all thank you mr. Tim thank you very
much I've got a few questions first of
all arm well only in fact on that the
Junior School mat it's quite a way to
codon from from the Roebuck some people
would walk it I'm sure
actually so what are you asking for and
when we're asking eventually we would
get support of SDC with actually County
Council to perhaps have a crossing over
here kept trading a straight face yeah
okay thanks councillor Bowers is the
transport man at the moment when
yes there has they have been
negotiations for crossings done by the
grammar school and this piece and other
questions nope
thank you very much counselor just just
what I remember I'm sorry it's not a
technical question but we have heard
twice today about how grateful people
are to our developers and officers for
working with the developers and the
parish and town councils and I think
that goes through actually for all of
the developments we've heard so far
today so it's just for me as a chair
thank you to the officers and thank you
to our developers as well things are
looking good so sorry about that the
questions technical to the officers
counselor I could see quite a lot of
landscaping that audio is that's all
going to stay in place or is that coming
as similar coming out I think it is
staying intact
yeah all around the periphery the
significant amount is about 16 meter
wide tree planting that although that is
outside the site we're still going to
have three meters inside the site and
I've actually conditioned along the
sensitive western boundary for
additional details for the landscaping
to be submitted so we're going to get
more trees inside the site as well and
all this existing tree planting along
this area here and then these are the
rear of the properties actually they
that's outside the site to an extent but
again all of that is being retained so
this vistors are going to be softened
considerably by this existing planting
this might be a bit stupid really but is
there a noise problem when that grows or
was the bun tying up in the trees enough
to absorb three
there is there's been a detailed noise
assessment that was submitted on the
original outline permission and there is
a condition required on the outline
permission there to require them to
submit noise mitigation measures which
the applicants are in the process of
doing so however what's important for
members to note is that the
environmental health officer has that
very careful look at the layout and
orientation of the dwellings and he's
happy that both the layout and
orientation are acceptable yeah okay
can't cancel Jones I'm just gonna deal
with some of the things that were raised
by so I think one of the issues was that
is it possible to have a condition that
the buffer with three meters along the
western boundary is it sounds like
that's a condition that's already there
so it is provided already so it needs to
be in accordance and importantly this
landscape buffer is outside of any of
the domestic curtilage a--'s it's the
the properties are primarily orientated
sidon or face on so they that will be
retained and then the business about
having the flood mitigation i mean
between the target i can see there's
obviously a difficulty there but i
wonder if you could maybe elaborate that
the i it's a question I think that
councillor Adams raised it went towards
the beginning of the application
obviously we need to ensure this
citation read is confined to this
application site we can't require the
drainage from a yet to be agreed scheme
to come forward with this application
what we have to what we have had clear
reassurance from the LOF a is that this
site can function independently of the
South development to the South however
when the southern site comes on board
its will function in a combined manner
okay so we're going this pedestrian
refuge in
the students is that conditioned so yes
the pedestrian refuge is the access
Arrangements into the site which
includes a pedestrian refuge is required
as part of condition 7 and it needs to
be implemented in accordance with the
approved details by the 20 occupation of
the 25th dwelling on site so that's
pretty early on in the development okay
to be to be fair it makes sense to have
that coming forward a bit earlier I mean
unfortunately that is a condition and
imposed by the inspect okay by
McCutcheon and become okay a note by the
looks of it on something something about
an additional I guess that's right for
the developer but we're talking about
going to the to the junior school Oh to
the north north to the junior school the
what the access arrangements have been
agreed that's that may be something that
could come forward as part of still
something help is a little bit out yet
does that mean crossing the bypass I
know it means cross it crossing the
access road to the northern there's a
northern island desert as a disjunction
which goes over an access road to
actually there is a refuge and as part
of the northern there is a footpath and
we'd go down what we're trying to
outline it is requires a refuge as well
a northerly direction together with a
foot way I think Ansel Adams was looking
for something extra further on
there's another road further if you
wanted to go further to cotan to the
Junior School there which actually some
of these people will and some of these
people will actually walk that distance
but it hasn't been conditioned already
we can't okay but we can work something
outside this committee can you make any
comment on this two-story nine meter
high business covered by the inspector
in the original outline and there is a
condition condition in 11 on the
original outline permission which
requires the reserved matters that we
have maximum Ridge Heights over no more
than nine meters all the dwellings are
dear to this and they've got the
existing and proposed level details so
it would be it is controlled okay
construction management plan that also
is in the outline for that line okay
lights along the a 435 now this is light
spillage I guess out so that if you're
driving along the 8th or 35 this as much
as possible still looks like uninhabited
fields so the west so the lights along
the western boundary housing lights
streetlights there's no lighting
condition in here apart from talking to
worksheet County Council so if we can
have that agreed with us as well sorry
I'm sure it would have been on the
outline permission that's normally where
we placed that to spare with me for a
moment while Louise looks for that yeah
Oh condition 10 it's already on that
yeah okay
any other questions captain organ Adams
mentioned about the public footpaths
that runs through the site whether that
will remain open during the construction
or not the intention is chaired that it
will remain open it's always possible
that the developer will come forward for
it with a request for a temporary
closure that won't be held until by us
it'll be handled by the County Council
it's something we don't
any control over but certainly as things
stand we're expecting it to remain open
other questions thank you very much so
to debate any comments castor bonds I
think it's nice to see everybody's
working together come up with a plan
obviously the inspector made a few
conditions which I don't know but as far
as I'm concerned you know proposed the
development thank you so know where the
road is and let's move forward I'm
looking for a second down that okay add
counselor Charles just want to say I
think it's really positive developers
have brought forward a design which is
you know it's not the norm I think it's
got some some distinctiveness and
uniqueness to it and it just makes such
a big difference and it's a quite
prominent sight so I know it's sort of
covered in the landscape but people will
will see it and I just think it's really
welcome okay let's vote to the vote all
those in favor of garlic planning
permission thank you very much that we
have resolved grant planning permission
1701 Oh 8 for no and there's another 170
no 108 for REM yes it is
- hot so we're moving on now to the next
application which is a full application
and a listed building consent
application for lychgate cottage Church
Street welfare on Aven and if we could
hear about that please thank you chair
the application of sight lies in the
center of Welford uh Navin village which
is a category two local service village
and the position of the site is denoted
by black dot which is also within the
built-up area boundary of Welford on a
even neighborhood plan the application
site is outlined in red village gate
cottage is located on Church Street and
is a grade 2 listed terrorist property
which lies within the wealth and
conservation area the property is
physically a joining us on to church
view the application is for both full
planning and listed building consent to
demolish an existing single-story
utility stroke boot room and erect a new
single-story extension with some
internal alterations this is the area
which is proposed to be demolished so
looking at it from the neighboring
property here this is it enough floor
plan so this is a boot room proposed to
be removed and it is proposed to link
onto the existing historic rear
extension and erect a new extension
measuring 5 meters by four point four
meters with a Ridge height of 3.7 so
basically continuing the ridgeline of
the existing extension
so this is a view from the next-door
neighbor this is within the site itself
so this is the new area of development
and then this is the new rear elevation
sort of looking at the back of the
garden back to the house
turning now to photographs actually one
pointer here it's the combined length in
terms of the extension when when
combined with the existing would result
in development of 9.5 meters in length
and a height of three point seven meters
it's turning the foot to the photographs
this is the front of the property this
is a view from the side so this is the
single story extension to proposed to be
removed this is the rear view looking
back towards the house and then these
are a view from the next-door neighbor
that's Church view and then this is the
rear elevation of Church view so with
key considerations as a positioning of
windows the recommendation is to reviews
both the full and listed building
consent applications from the reason I
set out on page 111 of this agenda Thank
You chair I just like to clarify for
members so that they fully understand
that you're about to be decide to
applications we group them together in
one report but there are two
applications in here I'd like to remind
the members who attended the heritage
training and possibly to inform those
who didn't that listed building
decisions are based on totally different
legislation to planning when making this
decision you you have a statutory duty
to have special regard to the
desirability of preserving the listed
building its setting and any features of
special architectural or historic
interest possesses
so what's special about this the
buildings is that they can easily be
harmed by inappropriate alterations if
not designed carefully to complement
that
building your conservation officer has
objected to this application and made it
very clear that it is possible to design
an acceptable extension the applicant
has chosen not to follow that advice
which is why your officers are
recommending refusal of the list of
building part of the the application in
front of you thank you
are you just to clarify that our
officers recommend a confused
refusal of the normal planning
application yes chair this was just to
separate out the two applications
okay well we'll go to that in technical
questions so we'll go to our speakers
now from the parish council of Welford
councillor James Kimpton and we have you
down here as objecting but you can
clarify that good evening dr. parish
council support the application subject
to the approval of the listed buildings
officer so while the PC was not unhappy
with the application we quite we've got
liked the design it should be considered
an objection until the applicant and the
OBO able to reach agreement on the
design we actually like the design but
we would defer to the holistic buildings
officer thank you any set that okay
other thank you are there any questions
councillor Richards so just so I'm clear
if we were to grant let's say tonight
you would still be happy with that
because you're happy with the design but
you want us to make sure that we're
happy that the listed building officer
is happy we're happy with the design and
if you were minded to grant it tonight
we will be happy with that yeah okay
Cara Jones
to put but what I'm I think what I'm
understanding from you the comment
that's come in
you're saying you're happy with it it's
only for the low listing listed
buildings officer is happy and my
understanding is the listings bill
listed buildings officer is not happy so
therefore it seems to me as though
you're saying that you support the
application to refuse because our listed
buildings officer is not happy because I
don't know parish council do not know
whether any other designs have been put
forward to the listing bill listed
buildings officer to be considered
because come back to us so when we had
our parish council meeting there were no
objections from any neighbors mindful of
the conservation area and mystic
buildings and we bow to better judgment
than ours from a listed buildings
officer it's complicated for us because
we don't we liked the design but we felt
that we should go with the listed
buildings officer then again it's
subjective and it's open to use members
of the council committee I think that's
a very cleaner explanation of a
difficult position and no more questions
thank you very much and now we will go
to the agent Steve Ellison
good evening Allison sorry three minutes
good evening my name is Steve Olsen I'm
a chartered architect at Brock Charles
and we are agent for the applicant Brock
Charles work extensive listed buildings
in conserving preserving and enhancing
our heritage assets in Warwickshire and
we agree with the council that the
quality of these historic examples
should be protected in our area the
dwelling was listed in 1931 now planning
and listed burning case and applications
here before you tonight are simply to
replace a poorly designed and now
structure and sound utility room
extension which is attached to the
original timber framed annex of the flat
roof dwelling
we are also relocating some internal
rooms without altering the heritage
asset internally the replacement
extension is sympathetic to the listed
dwelling and is only before you due to
the opinion of the conservation officer
otherwise both applications were
supported by both the Parish Council and
the district councillor for all of the
positive reasons that the improvement
clearly shows it is proposed to remove
the structurally condemned poor utility
room addition for a cohesive replacement
extension it is also proposed to
relocate the existing kitchen and
utility room spaces given that the
existing kitchen is extremely narrow as
you can see from the existing floor plan
presented to you by the planning officer
tonight we located the kitchen within
the existing annex allows for the
utility room functions to move to the
existing small kitchen space the garden
room extension includes a small bathroom
the replacement extension is proposed in
high quality materials compared to that
it replaces which is an evolved
structure with an asymmetric roof in
both stone painted brick and painted
timber cladding walls Flatley walls that
purchase the structure report condemned
the extension
the proposed oat frame guardroom matches
the historic annex in reclaimed clay
plain roof pitches and with timber doors
and windows throughout and so that the
applicant has proper access to their
garden and which they can now enjoy
directly from larger fenestration we
lays with the contract we liaised with
the conservation officers during the
planning application and although she
suggested alternatives very late during
the submission her ideas lack clarity
and were not suitable for the applicants
needs making it up making an existing
poor situation worse happily with the
support of the community we are before
you tonight finally I would like to read
a statement from the applicant who is
unable to attend tonight due to illness
since being lucky enough to only gate to
Cottage in there for the past two years
this has allowed us to fully appreciate
the character of both the cottage in the
village which we now call home
once we're aware from our structural
survey that the utility stroke boot room
required considerable structural
updating we believe that this will be
best achieved by rebuilding this section
as the proposed design to to enable us
to enhance the property and achieve our
required day living space it is our
intent to stop you there I guess like
the three men thank you I think we got
the gist of that are there any questions
no okay thank you mr. Ellison and now
councillor bonds thank you
yes this is we've got 42 listed
buildings within about 300 yards of this
particular property and the major
problem we have with listed buildings is
modernizing them or whatever you got one
day on Chapel Street where they want a
new kitchen well they can't have a new
kitchen because they don't move the wall
can't do the the plaster which isn't
plaster which is what Earl and dog and
obviously the best thing to do really is
to put a little bit on the outside which
is in keeping this is basically what
they're going to do trying to make the
house more habitable and keep the house
the listed building and the front of the
view as it is hundreds of people come
down this road to look at this far as
I'm concerned I went to the both
neighbors they were very happy with what
was said I think the planning officer
whatever her name was
she saw the neighbors as well and they
were both quite happy and we were
expecting me to sorta go through the
conservation architects that didn't like
this and didn't like that and didn't
like the bedroom change or something
there was talk of another plan which we
had a bit of a detail world I went to
and saw the neighbors I don't like that
which prefer the one we've got so the
situation is as far as I'm concerned
like the parish council it isn't too big
it's easy got the leads of people in
there too so that we don't have to
change the listed building which is I
can tell you on a lot of them because
they were there's one down the road
there was built in 98 right there to put
a bathroom in there is a bit of a job so
and that's older than the church so what
I'm saying is an extension like this
keeps the house
it is doesn't have the problem with
bottle until moving it'll look like
cities and various things as far as I'm
concerned I would hope that the
committee would support it thank you
very much any questions no Thank You
councillor Barnes I'm just going to get
one more clarification on the difference
between a full planning application
listed building consent I think we all
recognize the importance of listed
buildings heritage assets that's been
laid out in the in the report as well
but is this refused planning permission
on heritage reasons that for planning
permission were they refused on heritage
reasons can you clarify that sure if you
look at the reasons refused on the
bottom of page 111 you'll see that the
immediately after recommendation is
comes the planning application number
and the recommendation and then number
one is the heritage tourism yes when
considered with the existing extension
will be read by reason of its elongated
appearance an overly large have size
have an overbearing impact on the
amenity of the neighboring dwelling
that's a proper planning reason it's
quite separate from any list of building
considerations okay there's a proper
planning amenity reason there and then
the second one goes on to look at such
two reasons one of planning reasons and
one a heritage reason they're quite at
the bottom it's the separate list of
building reason which is purely there
which is peeling it okay right and we
will be having two votes on this any
other questions
no oh great debate councillor Giles I
thought the summaries that mr. Barker
gave is about the sort of law and the
nature and I decision-making was very
helpful because it's always worth being
reminded that actually a suit and the
purpose of listing a building is saying
well actually it's lightly taken outside
the normal planning discretion
and that there's a there's a real public
interest you know it's not just a
question of I'm a private owner so I get
to do what I want with my property
within the bounds of normal planning law
and discretion there's a real public
duty for us two statutory duty for us to
say are we and for me this is really
really simple where we have our own
expert conservation officer who objects
to this and it's not just a well on
balance objection a number of very
substantial reasons I set out on page
110 about why this extension because it
means it's not subservient sufficiently
so essentially what you do is you take a
little almost a little cottage type
building and by adding something quite
big you you get almost a big l-shaped
property rather than this sort of dual
cottage sort of situation and then the
second thing about neighbor amenity and
the point being is it doesn't matter
whether these particular neighbors
object to it it's about does it infringe
it does it cause an overbearing impact
on that property whoever was going to
live in it so I have to say I'm not
persuaded really by the excuse me the
particular personnel who say well in my
opinion it's okay
I'm very happy to rely on the expert
opinion we have here and for that reason
I would propose to refuse what both
applications and maybe they're taken in
a different order okay thank you cash
the organ thank you I have a contrary
view to my colleague here houses are for
living in they are homes as we've heard
quite difficult sometimes to
sympathetically change something from a
listed building to something that purely
makes it suitable for modern living and
it's a question of what is suitable and
what is not now we here in the report
that that we're told it's not suitable
but in reality there is more support for
it then there is objection
in reality the bit of the modern
extension that it is designed to replace
and to be fair to enlarge if that
existing extension were here in front of
us that would probably be refused as
well or be recommended for refusal we
also hear that the existing a part of
the extension that this is due to
replace it is unsound so something has
to happen to that it's a question of
what we also see in the reasons for
refusal that they are considered to
cause less than substantial harm they're
not in public view go to the rear of the
property and if it is something that's
going to cause lessen substantial harm
that is actually going to enable a
building to be properly lived in I think
I would support it okay thank you first
of all councillor Atkinson yeah chairman
could we have the existing illustration
on the screen to see what it's like I
think there was another one with more
definition of what the current extension
is viewing it from the site itself yeah
yeah the photograph that's it at the end
is it beautifully that what I I must
endorse good elements of what council
organ has said about public view I don't
suppose they it's open to the public so
therefore I find it a bit of an abstract
sort of reason to explain oneself away
as to what's the sensitivity is it not
what I would call something to behold
for a listed building now can we go back
to the what will be from the other side
the long roof the roof which has been a
sure
now that's the one yeah now the great
bit how much longer is that than the
existing roof line including the the
often extension on it compared with
sorry thank you it's what I'm just
trying to get compared with that exists
with the current extension so it's the
it's five meters so the existing is four
meters in length so it's an additional
service so coming back to our sort of
old-fashioned terms and about three feet
longer is that correct I think my
colleague and I need to have a
conversation before we give you a
definitive answer to this question thank
you
I'm happy to wait
could you bear with us a moment while we
take a measurement we we haven't made
that measurement so we can't take away
thank you I'm sorry in the interim yes I
would but I won't cancel it do you find
the same so I'm so just to be completely
clear I'm second in councilor jars
proposal to refuse counts are all going
to made the point that hazards are to be
are bought to be lived in I absolutely
agree with that but houses that are
bought with listed building consent when
one does that one agrees to live in it
within the leap constraints that and
listening building has so I don't think
just allowing it to be a bit more
livable is it an appropriate reason to
outweigh the harm that's been identified
by our listening building officer this
looking at that picture on the bottom
lights I actually that looks okay it
looks reasonably in keeping with the
building's safe for the glazed areas
Louise would you mind very you got a
handful to flick to the photo that
George showed us George wanted to see
Valda we can see there the glazing on
the extension there is very much in
keeping with the existing glazing
whereas what we're looking at and the
other one is big walls of glass that to
me is not in keeping with a listed
building if it had been more akin to
what we're looking at here then I think
I'd be a little more amenable to it but
we do have advice from our office our
listed building officer Florence or a
conservation officer to say that it's
not in keeping it does have harm by
virtue of having harm therefore we
should be refusing unless there's
benefit probably benefit to outweigh
there is not a nun's been identified
we're also told that there is a way of
extending this building that would be in
keeping and would be beneficial but that
hasn't been explored yet so so on that
beta on that basis one can only conclude
there is harm it's not been outweighed
by any benefit and therefore this should
be refused on that basis which is why
I'm happening ok can we answer cataract
concerns the question we can answer
counselor Atkinson's question after
making allowance for the demolition
that's going to take place the extension
will be 3.1 meters which in old money is
10 feet long 10 feet longer ok it's
great now do you really need to go ok ok
great thank you so one more for me I
believe that you can that that making an
extension is is it is a valid reason
making the house more livable is a valid
reason to overcome harm to overcome harm
in us because if you can't make it
livable it nobody lives in it and a
deteriorate so there is a there is an
argument for an extension I don't think
there's an argument for this extension
so we'll go to the vote
the proposal and the second is to the
first vote we will go to the first vote
which will be for the planning
permission the full permission 18:03 4
to 7 full with the reasons of
overbearing us and the heritage reasons
are you second in both councilor ok
thank you
it would be unhelpful so for that all
those in favor of granted of refusing
planning permission three German all
those against abstentions - okay so
we've resolved to refuse planning
application default and now the second
application 1803 four to eight listed
building consent same same conditions
same suggester and second all those in
favor of refusing listed building
content three chairmen against
abstentions - so we've resolved to
refuse that as well thank you and we'll
go swiftly on to the next application
which is hillside Alveston Lane
harvestin and Louise again thank you
Thank You chair this application is a
section of 73 application for the
amended sighting of a detached dwelling
the application site lies in the western
edge of Alveston village which is a
category four loop of service village
and the position of the site is denoted
by the black dots which is also within
the built-up area boundary of the
stratford-upon-avon neighborhood plan
the application site is aged in red
planning consent was granted for a
replacement dwelling for hillside in
2017 in a similar position to the
existing dwelling the property known as
meadow cottage who joined the site and
other neighboring properties friends
onto Alliston Lane and a cited to the
south of the application site the access
to the site is via a long private access
Drive which serves both hillside and
meadow College part of the access Drive
is within the conservation area and a
public footpath is located to the east
of the site
it's denoted by the green dashed line
now on the left plant here is the
sighting of the dwelling as approved in
2017 on the right is the amended
sighting as proposed by this application
which basically sets the proof dwelling
further back into the site by ten point
seven meters the green dotted line
denotes the position of the detached
dwelling approved in 2018 which is not
subject to this application at all and
also the green dotted line also
represents the position of the sunroom
which is being relocated as part of this
application so just a recap green dotted
line as the location of the approved
dwelling red is the original dwelling
and it basically is moving it ten point
seven meters further back into the site
the blue line shows that the rear
elevation of meadow cartage lines up
with the front of the replacement
dwelling the this plant shows the
elevations of the replacement twirling
these have been approved previously as
have the finished floor levels and the
current application only six amendment
of the siting the garage wing would be
the closest part of the dwelling nearest
meadow cottage this plant shows a
section through the site and the level
changes for both the existing and
proposed dwelling we're looking in a
southerly direction here so back towards
the Alveston Lane so back to the
properties the plant details the
distance between meadow cottage and the
existing property hillside which is that
the red dotted line here that's existing
dwelling this is meadow cottage and the
bold orange line here denotes the
replacement dwelling
a there is a 600 Miller millimeter
difference between the ground level of
the proposed garage and the ground level
of meadow cottage and there's a
separation distance of nine point four
meters between the site gable of the
meadow cottage and the site gable of the
garage the eaves of the garage proposed
garage measures 2.5 meters above ground
level and the ridge measures to 6 meters
so when assessed for a meadow cottage
this equates to 3.1 meters to the eaves
and 6.6 to the ridge were measured from
meadow cottage there to the main
two-story element of the replacement
dwelling would be sited over 20 meters
from the side boundary of the site from
the height of there now turning to
photographs this is a view of the rear
elevation of mega cottage here and the
rear elevation of hillsides and the
extension would be located replacement
dwelling would be were located in this
vicinity here this is a view from the
public footpath so firstly at the bottom
this is the site elevation of meadow
cottage so the replacement dwelling
would start approximately where the end
of medico teach is and this is their
garage and this is view looks like the
further down the footpath replacement
dwellings in this vicinity here
lastly this is a view from within
hillside itself and the metal cottage so
its replacement starts in the back
approximately there the recommendation
chair is to grant the application as
subject to conditions set out in page
122 of the agenda thank you thank you
very much we don't have any comments
objection from the Town Council but we
do have an objector a neighbor mister
hater so if we get here for mr. hater
thank you and you have three minutes
press the button in the middle till the
lights go red and I'll give you a two
and a half minute warning thinking there
is an important difference in the ground
levels and the house Heights between
meadow Cottage and hillside that doesn't
really come across clearly in the
committee report and this is critical to
determining this application the
difference in ground levels is naught
point 6 meters where the garage will be
sited rising to 1.9 meters for the house
and therein lies our huge concern the
raised ground level is marked on the
picture there by the yellow dashed line
in the photo taken from our patio
looking west towards hillside it's three
meters to the top of that fence and I'm
shown in front of the rock where the
recited house when we smack over that
fence there that's for the house itself
it's 9.2 meters it's 35% taller than our
house this makes the problem even worse
the difference in levels in the reciting
of the house ten point eight meters back
combined to cause a serious overbearing
problem that is entirely avoidable by
locating the replacement house further
forward to leave it in the location
you've already approved which we
supported the house extension guidelines
and draft development requirements SPD
recognizes that significant changes in
levels can affect overshadowing and
overbearing even when the guideline
angle and separation figures are in
compliance this all means that in the
proposed position house towers above
ours by four point three meters that's
over 14 feet causing an overbearing
impact on my house and garden the only
building line of consequence in terms of
urban designs the frontages of the two
houses facing south the frontage
building line of the two houses is just
not respected and if approved there
would be a staggered in Congress
building line causing harm to the
character of the
in summary the poor urban design and
harmful visual impact caused by reciting
the proposed house ten point eight
meters behind medica Taj is exacerbated
by firstly the greater height of the
proposed house being nine point two
meters compared to mine at only six
point eight meters that's the 35%
secondly the rising ground levels from
south to north this is a one point three
meter rise in levels from the frontage
building line to the front of the
proposed house this combination causes
the proposed house to unduly dominate
its surroundings the proposed amendment
to position the house conflicts with NDP
policy be9
causing it to become too dominant and
adversely affect the amenity of our
house on such a larger second on such a
large plot there was just no physical
constraint or any valid reason for
reciting the replacement house behind
the shared building line resulting in a
staggered effect poor urban design and
definite harm to my amenity I ask you
committee to please not allow the Syl
amendment to be granted and keep it how
it was thank you thank you very much are
there any questions
catch the bounce the photo that you've
brought presumably that's you there is
that soil up to the bottom of the fence
or a wall that's a wall I mean yes that
is me that's a wall immediately behind
me there the yellow that just shows that
the other cottage line how does your
land well that's the that's the nature
of the of the right the land rises in
two planes from north to south and from
from south to north sorry
so going effectively on that photo from
the left hand side to the right hand
side and it's also rising from where we
are here backwards okay
any other questions no very clear thank
you very much thank you
and we will hear from the agent
representing the African mr. Steve
Bromley the war so has three minutes
good evening and tell you at two and a
half minutes yes thank you German
planning permission has been granted for
a replacement dwelling at Hillside my
client is seeking a minor reciting of
the house further back into the site the
proposed amendment is for reciting only
there are no other changes the design
and levels stay exactly the same as
previously approved we have looked very
carefully at the relationship of the
proposed house to the neighboring
property meadow cottage at its narrowest
point the house will be 23 metres from
meadow cottage I distinguish between the
proposed house which is a two-story part
and the proposed garage which is
single-story there are no first-floor
windows looking towards a neighbor other
than a small window to an ensuite which
would be obscure glazed impacts on
neighbors amenities are assessed against
the council's 45 and 25 degree guidance
the blue line on the drawing indicates
the 45-degree line taken from the
nearest ground floor window you can see
that the proposed house is well outside
the 45-degree line the officers report
explains relationship with Medic cottage
very clearly and in detail on page 121
of the committee papers concluding in
the last paragraph on page 121 but the
proposals comply with policy and are
acceptable it should be noted that the
proposed house will be much further from
the neighbor than the existing house
that is to be demolished the existing
house is shown in red on the drawing
instead of being 7 meters from meadow
cottage the proposed house will be at a
distance of 23
meters as a consequence of relocating
the replacement house much further from
the mayor than the existing house
there'll be less overshadowing of the
Davis property because the proposed
revised sighting will be further to the
north or Northwest in the approved
position it will also cause less
overshadowing than the approved scheme
which is due west of the neighbor there
have been comments about a building line
implying that there will be a loss of an
established building line insofar as
building lines are concerned Part D of
the draft development requirements SPD
explains that established building lines
relate to continuous street frontage
development hillside is set in a
Backlund location and totally unrelated
to any street frontage there is no
established building line in this
location and therefore no harm will be
caused to the character and appearance
of the landscape 30 seconds this is a
point also covered in the officer's
report the proposals for this mind
reciting comply with council policy
chairman thank you for your attention
and hope you support the application
thank you very much
Kassar Richards Thank You mr. Romney I'm
unclear as to why the dwelling is being
recited could you explain to me why the
applicant doesn't have to say why he
wants to recite 'you have to find harm
in the development but as far as i'm
aware it comes from a discussion between
my client and the neighbor i wasn't by
to do it i don't know what was said
precisely but it was in the context of
the neighbor withdrawing his objection
if it was cited further forward I would
would stress that the planning officer
has not requested the dwelling to be
moved forward in the original
application yes it was moved it was
moved forward again my client originally
proposed it in the
position you're showing now that's where
he always wanted it partly because we've
had mainly because he can then continue
to live in his existing house whilst he
constructs a new dwelling and would say
since the planning permission was
granted previously my client has a
larger family on suddenly had a baby
boys now got three young children and he
wants less disruption when he builds a
new house so he can continue to live in
the existing house when he builds the
new house just behind it that was a
principle reason okay I think that's
fine considering you actually not
required to tell us any of this it is
helpful thank you Kay arkinson chairman
could I have the original slide on the
screen where mr. Hager was standing in
front of the fence
yes yeah I'm right in thinking that's
hillside there well we can see the two
windows and the chimney hillside gesture
matters hillside and that is going 23
meters now go to the one we've just had
on please so I can absolutely certain in
my own mind not very technical on these
things and it's going to be rotated at
the end of the dotted line is that right
see the blue line this hill show the red
dotted line no here on this point yeah
yeah so the wall you were looking at is
here where this pointer is pointing can
you see that yes and the proposed new
dwelling is this black outline here yes
two-story parties here yeah I'm a
single-story fog-gas yes fine okay and
that's the 45° stuff correct yeah yeah
okay thank you very much here yeah okay
no other questions okay sir organ the
total height of the garage part is up to
the roof yes I believe it's six meters
okay thank you thank you very much it's
great and now we will hear from cancer
loft as the ward member who has five
minutes
Kyoichi imagine you're living in one of
the two houses only in the middle of a
field and where the two houses have been
in the same building lines since they
were built many years ago
imagine the owner of one of the houses
decides he would like to knock his house
down and rebuild it a whole house with
further back out of alignment with the
house they store well that's what
happened every year ago and neighbors
myself and the APA objected of course
quite a stir and the planner at the time
was putting it forward for a refusal the
owner decided that he would put it back
in line the application was approved
with the support of the village and
myself the world member well the owners
society wants a small amendment entitled
minor reciting and put the house back a
whole whipped out of alignment with the
house next door because he wants to
remain in the original house whilst the
next one is built this is not planning
reason and it is not a minor amendment
what I spoke to the planner on this
application she did say she would prefer
it in the original agreed position in
line with the next-door neighbor and yet
it's been put forward for granting this
is ridiculous it contravenes many
policies one being the neighborhood plan
b e9 the new position of the proposed
house would be overbearing and over
dominant to the house next door and
causes staggered building line causing
harm to the character the proposed house
would be much taller and wider and
appear over dominant because the level
of the land rises it will be so
intrusive you may think that because
it's in the middle of the field no one
will notice well what about the
neighbors next door who will see a whole
house from every window of theirs
instead of a garden and a field it will
have such a huge detrimental of
on them so I reiterate imagine yourself
living in meadow cottage next door and
waking up in the morning looking out to
see a huge dominant house instead of
fields in the garden police committee
refused this amendment and asked that
the applicant accept the original of
approved application thank you thank you
very much near questions council Giles
if you can help me with what precisely
be9 of the neighborhood development plan
that says because I don't have it to
hand yes I can it's about overbearing
and over dominance of any property being
out of character with the rest of the
street seed okay
councillor organ can you put your mic
off counselor comes in two days
councillor kimsen okay thank you so he
is any other questions
no thank you very much okay technical
questions the officers have we got any
I'll start with just a question on the
25 degree if is there twenty five degree
line going upwards have we considered
that sure I know you don't like it when
I give you long lectures there is a 25
degree rule line it's not relevant in
this instance because the 45 isn't
crossed I can okay okay Thank You
councillor palms you know the board
members said that the original house the
people living would be overlooked or
they will be able to look in another
property if that's the case in the 25%
spent over 45% must be broken yeah what
was that what's your point
oh the point really is if they move in
the house next to the one we saw the
picture on then obviously it's going to
stop the light isn't it but it isn't you
saying
we'll be looking at not the open fields
it's it's a complex answer and I'm
struggling to work out how to to phrase
it in a way that's magical and
understand you know I might understand
you man ya know that he's understandable
if you look at the the plan in front of
you you can see that there is a dotted
blue line that's the 45-degree line
drawn from the center of the window of
meadow Cottage to effect the light it
would need to fall foul that the new
dwelling would need to foul that line
and it doesn't but that doesn't mean
that there won't be some loss of light
in the garden of meadow Cottage officers
assessment is that because of the the
relative position because the the house
is so far away from the boundary and
because the Sun is up in the sky as
opposed to down a ground level that
there will be very little if any loss of
light loss of sunlight and there will be
very little if any overbearing impact
from the dwelling because of those
relationships but there may be a very
very small amount we can't deny that
okay thank you Kara organ thank you
we've heard NDP policy be9
and that it states that replacement
dwellings must be of appropriate scale
so as not to be too dominant or
adversely affect the immunity of
neighboring uses could the planning
officer please comment on this and how
it actually is used to interpret this
application I think I've largely
answered that question in the comments
I've I've just made the policy doesn't
intend to prevent any
change happening yeah what it's intended
to do is to prevent harm and the
assessment that officers have made is
that the harm is minimal or possibly
even nil that's the assessment officers
you made now members are perfectly
entitled to come to a different
assessment if they wish to but the
policy is it he's looking at loss of
daylight loss of privacy adverse
surroundings unacceptable levels of
noise unacceptable levels of company of
contamination officers have looked at
that and have concluded that the levels
are acceptable very slight and therefore
acceptable members can come to a
different conclusion if they so wish
haven't seen the presentation okay
counselor love allow you to speak if you
want to want at this point and not later
on if it's a matter of fact and
clarification so please I do apologize I
have to confess I get completely the
wrong answer to that last question I was
looking at policy cs9 not be a night it
looks like if that's what you were going
to talk about you can save it to later
if you like
thank you very much councillor Ralph
yeah
policy benign of the neighborhood plan
states that a replacement dwelling must
be of an appropriate scale so as to not
be too dominant or impact on the amenity
of neighboring occupiers I think most of
the rest of my previous answer stands
not to be too dominant or impact on the
amenity of neighboring occupiers there
the two tests is it dominant does it
have an acceptable impact on the amenity
of neighboring occupiers and that's the
local that's a neighborhood plan
neighborhood plan policy benign it has
full weight even if members feel that
the replacement dwelling is too dominant
and it does have an unacceptable impact
on neighboring occupies they would be
perfectly proper to the recommend
worship to decide to refuse the
application okay thanks apologize to my
my error previous agenda going on two
different questions right any other
questions nope thank you so we're open
to debate councillor Giles thank you I
think there's a good reason we have
building lines and to me it's not
relevant that it's not in the context of
a long street scene the purpose of there
being a building line one of the not
it's not just so that in general there's
a continuity of building that although I
think that's important one of the
reasons is is because actually if you
want to look out of your windows into
your back garden it's it's a pleasant
thing for everyone to be able to look
out into open space if everyone has to
then look out onto big buildings you
know it's an interference with amenity
as far as I'm concerned because of the
particular land rise here which
exacerbates the situation in my opinion
this is dominant it therefore has the
ability to impact the amenity of the
guard and not with it might well be that
in a normal course of things because of
the separation distance that wouldn't be
the case but because of the lung levels
in my view there is an overbearing
impact so I would personally want to
propose a refusal on the basis that it
is in contravention of benign and it's
its dominant and it has an unacceptable
overbearing impact on neighbor amenity
particularly their garden space thank
you
Cossack Anson just looking at the
illustration which mr. Hayter sent the
neighboring house seems to be very close
and much closer compared with the
proposal bearing in mind that the first
thing to be there is a garage which will
be single-story what we don't know is
the gradient factor and I would tend to
assume they must be dramatic
in order to
a dominant position were compared from
the new structure compared with what we
see on the illustration provided by mr.
hater I can't follow councillor Giles
reasoning actually she hasn't mentioned
what the the grading factor is that
tender thing he must have to be like
Mount Everest
we were told I have quoted it but there
is a there is a ground level rise and
it's obvious from the photographs but if
you want me to quote the figure of
ground rise in the reasons it can be put
in councilor box I was just checking
really that it does appear to me that
the garage is on the same level the
concerned neighbor and then the big
house obviously goes a lot further so
it's basically what is the distance
between the two properties which is
important he produces closeness we said
we could refuse but as far as I can say
it looks to be reasonable distance to me
because of the the light factor that
we've already gone into okay any other
no oh yes sorry yeah on on a matter of
fact please it's not sort of yeah facts
and
the first matter of fact is that the
proposed garage is the same height as
the current building and that the the
the actual amount of house that is moved
to that way is 10 meters which is wider
than this room 10 meters that's how much
it's gonna move across that's how much
medica touch will see that amount of
house a whole house that's clear thank
you thank you so what's that a couple of
minutes I mean does yeah
would you like to reply to that or not
can you can you eat we'll do that here
this will be it said it's gonna be a bit
tit-for-tat but that's the problem with
this that's what we have to accept I
have to contradict that factually that's
incorrect you can see from the section
that the garage is lower than the
existing house it's also got a heatproof
okay thank you very much so that's that
over with I'm actually drawn to
councillor Giles argument in in a field
where where it could go anywhere and the
existing house is in line and doesn't
cause any harm and the proposal was in
line and didn't cause any harm this
causes some harm it's quite obviously
causes some harm because it can be seen
completely from just outside the back
door when you're in your garden living
space it will have it won't affect the
light but it might affect even evenings
but it's a difference from from
absolutely nothing which would be an in
line situation to plunked in right
behind the building right the back
building
so it's all visible and there is rising
land so I think this is poor design
spatial design and I quite agree with
your amenity and overbearing in in this
circumstance seems quite logical to me
and I shall second note
but you want me to read that out I do it
this is this has come in as which
actually sums up exactly what you've
said I don't think we need to know
whether it's sort of worth hunting two
reasons because what you touched on it
because to me there's the the issue of
moving it forward which has the impact
on neighboring amenity but then the
issue about it not being in keeping with
the building line is a design issue and
I agree that is a separate reason it
causes actually I know I know the
assessment of the report is it not being
in a building line in this particular
location doesn't matter but but that's
actually the part I disagree with I
actually think as you said it's actually
poor design for there not to be an in
keeping building line here and I don't
know that's the second reason it's not
something I particularly go for I think
it's just not not keeping in line with
with the building line to prevent harm
so it's just poor design because it's
not in line I don't think the look of it
in this situation with three isolated
houses is relevant okay we've got that
we'll go to the vote the first vote
perhaps all those in favor of refusing
this planning application please vote
now German 3 German all those against
refusing this application German all
those abstaining German thank you so we
have resolved to refuse application 1803
256 very
that good idea Thank You Candace my
chair that refusal was for the reasons
you discussed yes we can agree with you
tomorrow absolutely.thank yes
I think they were quite clear reason
yeah there's no urgent business so we're
close the meeting thank you very much